il a consacré sa vie à l'engagement au
militantisme pour faire valoir les
droits de la communauté lgbt qu plus
l'héritage de laurent mais kitchen il
est notoire et les vastes
il a notamment milité longuement pour la
reconnaissance des droits des conjoints
et conjointes de même sexe combat qui a
mené à la loi en 1999 il a aussi présidé
pendant une vingtaine d'années
l'organisme guinée côte il a mis sur
pied la fondation émergence ii qui vise
à favoriser l'inclusion sociale des
personnes homosexuelles
en plus de contribuer à l a mise en
place de la journée internationale
contre l'homophobie et la transphobie
est ce qui ressort des commentaires des
gens qui l'ont côtoyé c'est la sobriété
du militantisme de leurs hommes
m'inquiètent chine et surtout sa
capacité à se créer des alliés et ce
bien au-delà des lignes de parti
politique
j'ai eu l'occasion je dis
malheureusement pour moi mais brièvement
de rencontrer peut-être à deux reprises
monsieur maquette chaîne qui était déjà
quand même un très malade et j'ai pu
sentir l'inspiration cet homme blanc
avait le l'impact qu'il avait au sein de
la marque u la communauté que ce mec-là
shon est quelqu'un qui a tellement fait
pour faire avancer la cause de l'égalité
de tous et de toutes
surtout de la communauté gb tiques puces
et
j'ai travaillé avec lui dès 2014 c'est
un homme extraordinaire
je pense que c'était sa responsabilité
comme leader il faut agir de cette façon
de dire on doit conclure des alliances
on doit convaincre les gens passeront
pas uniquement parlé à succès de jeux
convaincu parce que on n'avance pas une
autre cause importante pour l'europe
mais quelle chaîne le droit de mourir
dans la dignité il ad'ailleurs notamment
été récemment le vice président de
l'association québécoise du droit pour
mourir dans la dignité
et il en lui même reçu l' aide médicale
à mourir le 4 juillet dernier à l'âge de
65 ans alors qu'il était atteint d'un
cancer depuis 2016 son ami l'humoriste
et animateur dany turcotte était de ceux
qui l'ont côtoyé peu de temps avant sa
mort ouais bon nos super ensemble
notoire haussmann quelques jeux même
aller comment la fin mais je me rappelle
de change sauf le court au téléphone ces
quelques la dernière heure il me dit que
j'ai demandé l'aide médicale à mourir je
vais mourir à 10h25 était comme 10h15 sa
première fois de ma vie que je parle à
une personne qui vont mourir dans une
heure qu'est ce que tu lui dis hein je
lui ai dit merci pour tout ce qui est
fait pour nous ils étaient des centaines
à s'être déplacés ici à l'église
saint-pierre-apôtre à montréal pour
rendre un dernier hommage à laurent mais
quelle chaîne et souligné son héritage
issigeac audrey charbonneau radio canada
montréal